for decades britain's royal shakespeare
company has perfected the art of
dressing up it has a collection of
around 60 000 weird and wonderful
wardrobe items including some of the
most famous outfits in british theater
history from plays like taming the shrew
and hamlet and soon visitors will get to
see the making of the costumes up close
roxanna saberi gives us a
behind-the-scenes
look
in the birthplace of the bard the royal
shakespeare company performs his
classics i'll see the hand on sunday
first
and contemporary creations
i'm adele the brave
got it
within these walls all the world's a
stage
and these are the men and women who
stitch it together this is a squiffer
so it was designed for roughing up the
bottom of ballet shoes
so you're trying hard to make something
new look old
yeah
yeah that's quite and to give it to give
it a history
as the largest in-house workshop of its
kind in british theater it's dressed a
list of legendary actors from richard
burton as henry v to lawrence olivier
and vivian lee
head of collections robin greenwood
curates the company's most iconic
garments actors we've got ian mckellen
judy dench we don't just make theater we
make costumes we make a craft and
starting next year these unsung players
will get their chance to be front and
center when their recently renovated
workshop opens to the public for the
first time
so this is our women's costume studio
aleister mcarthur and his team gave us a
preview the sketches markups and pieces
from the bottom to the top for their
latest production these are part of um
it's the costume prop world part
magician's elephant are these real
feathers
yes it's very rare you can find stuff
like this on amazon that's gonna last a
hundred performances and that's why you
have to make it that's why we have to
make it
almost entirely by hand like in
shakespeare's day
alan smith has hammered out helmets
shields and swords for three decades
part of the reason why we do a lot of it
in-house is obviously it saves money but
also so we have a lot more creative
control leather breastplates take an
average of 70 hours to craft at my
signal
unleash hell some items have segued from
stage to scream appearing in gladiator
braveheart
and shakespeare in love pretty much all
the pieces end up at the company's
sprawling rental shop
manager pipisteri says each one is
marked with a label showing which actor
wore last
this is judy dench's dress from all's
well you trust it in somebody's hands
yeah because people know the history of
it and they know whose it is
they always kind of look after it with
60 000 items you can find almost
anything you're looking for somebody
wanted a life-size pigeon costume which
we don't have
everybody wants to dress up as a pigeon
no we don't have a pigeon we've got a
chicken costume in there there are also
crows heads and more each rental for
around 125
here you can also spot some behind the
scenes secrets
and then you have this which has got the
magnets so then that will stay and then
they're easy to take on and off a
costumes ultimate test comes after
months in the making every single detail
has been thought about and
helps you just embody that character
when the actor it was meant to serve
like summer stralin in the magician's
elephant puts it on
oh good thanks darling okay
for the team behind the seams all's well
this place is going to the dog that fits
well
for cbs mornings roxanna saberi
stratford upon even england
thank you roxanna you you catch that the
team behind the scenes
costumes make such a difference in
whatever it is you're watching halloween
2022. here i come
there we go so glad somebody's doing the
work looks like a fun place to work